yes
okay hello everyone welcome to another
design review
looking at future welcome language
functionality this is part of our
language completeness and consistency
series
and first up we have
knitting of map apply
right
so
um
yes this is a bunch of uh
right so we added mata map applying 13.1
and then you know we need to sort of
update
uh right so there are a bunch of places
which refer to
you know double add and triple at
and
uh you know it's both apply but of
course that's no longer true
um and then
the
question is and then there are a few
other places that maybe we want to apply
add
um one or more
yes
sorry i was making kind of a pun there
um
what the heck is this totally messed up
what the heck is this
what are you seeing well i'm just seeing
okay finally that that's a just a really
weird messed up collection of um
all right applying
functions to lists here is that correct
yep
just use that as a sample
oh gosh
hmm
that's messy
what do you propose to add
um
well i we could either
you propose to add map apply here
right i mean we could either add map
apply
there and you know say something like uh
you know apply to a function to elements
of a list
um
or we could you know sort of list both
of them on the previous line no i don't
think we should do that not for this
page
okay
i think for this particular page
or we could say a player function at
level one
no
well
levels we could say
right then it would be by analogy with
the previous line it would be apply a
function to the elements of the list
yeah why not
let me not put all this in there
okay okay
um
do i have to look at every single one of
these
um
i
i suppose that's up to you um if if
you're
okay with i mean the ones with the
question marks i think we we should look
at uh there are like four of them i
think i did this stupid thing
go back and search my whole i thought
we'd set this 500 times to not do this
uh well you know you can click on the o
box the o button next to open guide page
that'll give you something that only
scans oh okay fine that's what i need
okay
so here
um
pretty sure it was here so there it is
yeah
so just put on the next line here map
apply paren
yeah right so and then there's the
obvious
obvious generalization of of that line
no but i wouldn't well or you're just
saying just do it just do it in the in
the bulleted form not well the
definition
you know what it's useful enough just
give it on go give it a whole line okay
you think i mean
yeah i think i think that i think that
makes sense
i think it's significantly more
important than you know everything in
the line below
right
okay so now i say expressions here
what
right it's underneath the second green
line there yeah no way we do not need it
here okay
um
and then
lots of matrices
right so apply isn't on this page
should it be
um
well i i don't i don't think that's a
very common case but we do have map on
this page if we want to apply a function
to
uh so when map apply
is more useful than apply because apply
would chop the head off the matrix by
default
right and so map apply
you know depend right depending on
whether the function is scalar valued or
or vector valued the map apply will
either
keep a matrix as a matrix or transform a
matrix to a vector
right so if you want to you know
sum
the rows right well you could use total
but you could also map apply ace uh i
think it shouldn't be on this page i
think this is really a matrix as
matrices so to speak
okay
right
again right so we have the map family
here and so do we want to include
you know map apply along with map bat
map and map all
well this is about parts of expressions
so does map apply
relate to that
right so
i i suppose no i don't think so it's
pretty okay
okay
language overview know why
okay
no
okay
all right i can using these templates i
can fill out the remaining pages
sounds good okay
monitor
lizards or not
great so
right so this is sort of there are a
couple of issues we've discussed about
progress monitoring uh one of them is
sort of asking for thing monitoring
things which for very one reason or
another
it may be very difficult to sort of add
progress monitoring natively
um and also sort of how we package this
up
uh for users and so one idea like
monitor of map for example exactly and
so if you look at the examples
you will see a monitor of map in there
um
and and so you know you can there's a
screenshot there but of course you can
also evaluate those and
and and see it actually happen
right that's magnificent
okay
that's magnificent i mean i think
obviously we need a good way to display
this is [ __ ] i mean i'm sorry if i
might say so what are you doing here
this is the function map you've got to
say it's the function map don't invent
another name for it
is a demo just like put some random text
i i assume that this would have gone to
me we'll have to go through review or
something like okay fine right yeah yeah
yes this is this this is a prototype
maybe i didn't make that sufficiently
clear this is a prototype that we are
exploring
and and it's great the concept is great
the words aren't right
okay
okay so here
so this is a small breaking change like
uh
you see that we
if we want to to you to support this
this behavior together with the three
arguments forum monitor which allows for
the delay uh we need some
second argument to basically uh
stand in for the one argument form
so basically hold on hold on hold on
hold on hold on hold on
i'm not remembering what the third
argument of the monitor is
we will be to the syntax uh table is the
last is the last node
okay
you know what that should be an option
that just should be an option it
shouldn't be the third argument there
what analogy
don't we have other cases like for tool
tips where we have tool tip delays and
so on
yeah i mean it could be a progress delay
option if you really want to go with
that
well but what do we have in tool tips
i don't remember anything it's exactly
too deep delay i'm looking for it but
yeah okay tool tip delay
okay precise
yes i mean it's been not an option for
you know since version six so 15 years
yeah okay fine i understand that so we
would have to continue to support that
case
but i think we should move it towards
having
okay so we've got shrinking delay
so we might want to give it a very
specific name like monitoring delay
you see what i'm saying
yeah possibly
um here what options well we have a lot
of functions that display the progress
monitoring uh not just you know the big
training function but also like a little
video function we could use it we could
propagate it basically
yeah well monitoring delay
so
you know monitoring delay would just be
the amount of time to delay
how long to delay before starting to
monitor the function
so well
not
well that's not exactly true right
because it's monitoring it it's not just
not showing it okay before displaying
the monitor of the function exactly
before displaying progress so i mean but
that that's very bizarre to say progress
delay
that will be my initial right i mean
right the analogous option that we do
have is progress reporting which can be
true or false and maybe also automatic
so maybe it's just progress reporting
delay
right
why not progress reporting delay i mean
it's an obscure option most people will
never set it
right right
um
and i think that
uh
i mean i think independent of whether or
not it's an option i think it's good to
have a two argument a value for the
second argument which is equivalent to
the
one argument form just as a matter of
sort of language design so i don't think
we should not support automatic
but also i agree i agree we could
support automatic we can also support
some string values for that second
argument
potentially yeah i mean the the reason
why i pick automatic is
both because my mind automatic basically
means do whatever you should do yeah i
know i know and also because displaying
automatic as a monitoring thing is not
particularly interesting
so yes quite
sandra and livestream is suggesting
display delay
which is not a terrible idea maybe we
should
i'm not sure
i i'm not sure i think that that doesn't
feel quite right i can't quantify why
but
i think well we have a display function
it could
i think we should sounds more general
yeah
okay so
so i think this is magnificent are there
issues here about nested ones
is it if we say monitor of a table here
it will the monitor
will
process the
um
you know the the the iterator specs
and right notice how you see
that says 24 of 32 right so it
multiplied the four
the two of the sad face smiley face and
so monitor is a whole first argument
function right
yes
yeah i think it's probably hold all
right
okay
yeah
so but it is a function not a headdress
correct
so we are inventing a one argument form
to
um
[Music]
yeah the two argument formulas worked
fairly well so i'm not too worried about
it not being a headdress
um
so you were asking about what is if you
have a table inside the table
yeah but the basic point is it's the
approximate table that the monitor deals
with
so if you say monitor of foo of x it's
going to do nothing because because foo
is not monitorable
exactly and that was my my question
about like
should we design a system for the user
to obtain this
yes i think so but i mean i'm also a
little bit concerned about the
possibility i think there's an argument
that you should be able to say
okay if you say monitor of f of fold
should the monitor drill through the f
to get to the fold
well it can when it's literally present
what i don't like is why should be any
difference if fold is literally there or
not
no it's okay i mean that's okay it's
somewhat lexical
people are not i don't think that's look
the most common case here will be
that you're trying to debug something
and you stick this monitor in
you know that we can initially just do
it as a
pure
the thing it eats on the outside of the
sandwich if you understand what i'm
saying
you know it can it can just look at the
outermost function
that's okay i believe
great to begin with maybe we can later
on have some cleverer heuristic where it
can
drill in and find a function that is
monitorable
and already this would be a big project
i mean the prototype i have here is uh
is hacking the like this is implementing
uh like map with my map index is
modifying
uh
we will have to do it properly in the in
the c kernel to make it efficient so
yeah which we need to do
yeah so
yeah i mean i see like the there's a big
plate to make this happen and i think
while we do that we can have all sorts
of ideas
okay okay by the way sandra is asking
will it deal with correctly counting the
number of elements in a in a triangular
table
like a table i goes to 10 j goes to i
don't know what i'm saying yeah well we
can try it see what happens right i mean
it's in the prototype build so right
these examples are evaluatable i think
it will just break right now because i'm
assuming yeah that they are their
numbers so
so this case here let me say martyr this
it will probably say something like i
minus
something it's not not a number
okay
you need to make
an f
you need to put f around one of those so
it'll be slow enough or slow
uh to
write where do i put it
uh
yeah i define it with sub values yes
low f applied to that
yeah
this like this yeah
yeah okay oh it's updating well at least
it's updating in real time yes
i mean it's not great but that's better
than i expected
well it you could do an analysis but i
mean i mean i see the bigger problem is
the the semantics of the whole doll
thing but that's maybe that exists
already
full monitor
for monitoring yeah
well we've already crossed that
monitor's been doing that for years
right but
it's just right i mean but that's no
different from manipulate or any of
these other
right the issue is if you put it in like
echo doesn't have that problem so you
can just spray echoes into your code
with wild abandon
whereas with this
it might semantically change your code
if you had a block outside of this the
block wouldn't seep into the monitor
correctly
maybe it would but in that particular
block
should i mean yeah it should it should
do it should do it
but there might be some case where i
don't know i mean you know a case where
putting a monitor in would actually
change the behavior of the code
yes that's an issue so i mean there's a
couple of issues here so one thing is
um
we need language which says and for
goodness sake we have to give the name
of the function i mean we say
um
what do we usually say do we usually
have a verb here in a progress monitor
we say computing yes something like
processing frames
okay well i think what we should do is
to say basically map of and then we
should have this thing and then dot dot
dot
okay so we should have the beginning of
it
somehow so that we get the word the name
of the function in and we get an
indication of what
the thing its processing actually is
but obviously we should cut that off
because that could be completely huge
am i making
sense yep
i mean it basically would say evaluating
and then that may be in light gray and
then map of blah blah dot dot dot
yeah and then nest off okay fine i don't
know quite how to close the bracket for
that evaluating map and then maybe
well i mean we could just have map of
the beginning of the first argument
comma dot dot dot close bracket
maybe what we want to do
is yeah that this is going to look
better evaluating map of f comma dot dot
dot close bracket and if f is big it'll
say f dot dot comma dot dot close
bracket
that make sense
okay
now
other than that this just looks
magnificent i mean you know i think that
map mac and map index those ones are
clearly
uh you know you're gonna want map thread
a bunch of other things like that
um
uh
how exactly uh whether you need to
change names like
you know f
for nest you don't want to say
processing blah blah elements
do you
maybe you could
um well that's the default that they
didn't change it we could customize it
for some functions but right
this looks magnificent
anything else to talk about about this
right now other than this looks like a
really good idea
nope not really i'm still not sure about
how to
oh you use that user hooks use a hook
so my guess is that this will have to be
the only real way to do it is to have a
monitor value just like we have a format
value
for a symbol
do you see what i'm saying
well you need to pass at least two
values here yeah like what's the total
and what's the current
like two no i understand that i
understand that so so okay wait a minute
so we have
various kinds of you know step monitor
what how exactly those work we have a
step monitor you know what i'm saying
which is an expression to evaluate is it
not right
that's an expression that that
evaluates
you know right right so so then
you know what we could do
let's see
for user-defined functions
if the user okay so there are two cases
one is that
okay it's a user-defined function
[Music]
okay the two things we want
one is it's a user defined function and
it simply brings up this nice blue box
so that in other words what you do is
you say
somehow inside the body of the function
you simply have something which has some
callback mechanism i don't know exactly
how the blue box works internally
but um
uh
it's just dynamic
wow in in a notebook interface right
that's yeah it's dynamic notebook
interface and it's a scheduled task that
prints stuff in the terminal okay okay
but so so fine but what i'm saying is
there are two things we want one is that
the user be able to put up the blue box
that's case number one explicitly put up
the blue box and the other is to set up
a function where if you were to wrap it
with monitor it would put up the blue
box
do you get what i'm saying
oh well simply put up the toolbox is a
matter of documenting our our progress
monitoring wrapper i understand so
that's one thing to do okay
and the progress monitoring wrapper what
does it take
uh right now it works like monitor like
it
you give it an association with for
example like uh progress goes to i and
then i is the value that changes in your
function
there's an internal rough page so if you
were to open the page uh evaluate with
progress
in docutools you will see
document internal documentation for this
function
which is not in the system context it's
should we put it i mean should we make
it of wfr for the time being
[Music]
why not well the design might change so
what
that's the whole point for wfrs this
seems very useful i think you should put
it there just so we can play with it
um okay
so
great so i mean we should grind this
design and try and get it to be a system
function
uh
i mean maybe it should be called
monitored evaluate or something like
that
okay in any case so that that function
exists all right so then the next
question is
well you've got to have something where
normally you just define f of x blank
colon equals blah
but
if you wrap f with monitor then it
should be using evaluate with progress
instead of
so in other words what you're basically
saying is the params here have to be
available given the function f
you've got to be able to supply the
params
but are the params knowable without
knowing what expert is
do you understand what i'm asking i mean
doesn't that
other parameters the parameters contain
the explicit symbol i for example for an
iterator or do params say where to find
the iterator within x-bar
no no right now it's i
yeah is i i mean there's
nothing against supporting some uh if we
reserve some symbols
no no that's not what i mean that's what
i mean i mean because what we've got to
be able to do
is given a symbolic structure exper
that
you're now asking for the monitor of
expert
you've got to be able to pull in the
appropriate params to be able to make
the progress monitor for expert in the
appropriate way yeah right so right and
and and to be clear right what
what the demo that you've looked at in
that notebook does is well we have
standard iterator
specification so it completely ignores
the function and just looks at the
iterators and sort of does them one at a
time
right yeah i get it but it's going to
drop
dive into the table
to the symbolic table expression to find
the iterators right yeah exactly
right and then it is modifying the first
argument to evaluate something else uh
which is like you know i plus like
problems yeah okay i guess i get it i
get that i get it so so the issue there
is
that that means you're basically you
know you're mungering unevaluated code
when you give monitor
you want the user function to munch the
unevaluated code to essentially rewrite
the code to add evaluate with progress
in the appropriate way correct
well that's not necessary i mean the the
easiest way is to write your function
with progress in mind which should just
be there doing nothing and then you just
specify oh by the way when i'm wrapped
with monitor
the
variable progress is the one you want to
look at okay okay okay that's probably
better that's easier than
okay so that then
so you're saying
there are two cases of evaluated
progress
one is do it always
and the other is do it only when you're
wrapped with monitor
correct yeah i mean the reason why i
wasn't so uh
eager to document evaluative progress is
that you in principle you you don't even
need to to see that yeah
like if you write your code
in a way that tracks the the progress
then you just need a way to say
okay when monitor is around
just i understand that i understand but
if i progress for any function expert
produces the blue box with with certain
parameters in it correct
uh well if you don't give a second
argument it just says computing it just
gives you a blue box
right but yeah i mean yes
if they give some text
right right so what you're saying the
point you're making is we could have
a thing that is
that says i do nothing unless i am
called wrapped with monitor in which
case i produce a blue box
didn't sound what i'm saying uh yeah no
i i wasn't really saying that but that's
what you meant to say because it's the
right thing to say
that that's the thing that we want like
we want to function look the case that
we want that is
i'm not sure i'm not sure that's what we
want right i mean we have
right we have
right we have various functions which
support the
progress reporting
and i think they currently default to
dollar progress reporting
um
and and and so you know
right why shouldn't users be able to
implement things that way
i think it's less convenient than having
explicit monitoring maybe monitor can
work by resetting dollar progress
reporting
if necessary but i think the thing that
is convenient
is when you define your function f of x
blank
to have a wrapper
around the right hand side
that says
you know basically what we're talking
about is
f of x blank
colon equals
monitor when told to
of body
do you know what i'm saying
well yeah except i think that's
basically evaluate with progress
no it's not because the valley work with
progress always puts up the blue box no
it doesn't
right there's a delay option no no no no
no no forget the deal
i'm saying there are two and and then
you're right it consults dollar progress
reporting etc
does it
okay but i think the convenient thing
is to have a wrapper that is evaluate
with progress but to be used only when
there is an explicit monitor in calling
the f
because that's the analog that's the
direct analog of what we're going to be
doing with map
yes i know you've got to be able to tell
it
how to find those parameters from the
body
right that's exactly the analog of what
we're doing with map map by default does
not produce progress monitoring it's
only if you ask it to that it does it
yeah
okay but the the interesting thing is
the second argument of what you wrote
what was the spec there
doesn't i don't know i i no i i told you
i told you the thing i was saying before
which is you've got to be able to
evaluate you've got to be able to
rewrite the unevaluated code of body to
go and find parameters in it that you
are then going to monitor
do you get what i'm saying
yes but i'm not sure i agree why why
would you need to rewrite the code there
okay because you've got to extract
you've got something that says table
here and it's got an i in that weird
position in that symbolic expression
you've got to be able to extract that
eye from there
and use it with the same eye to put into
the monitoring thing that's the point
did you get it
but
but
the the only reason the only reason this
works is because we have deep knowledge
of what table does
yes i know right we don't go we don't go
spelunking through random functions i
know i know but i'm saying when a user
puts this in here
right
actually it isn't even necessary it
isn't even necessary the user can
specify what the parameters are here
the user knows what they are because
they've got the body here exactly that
was my point
you don't need to do rewriting yes
you're correct i'm sorry
i unfortunately need to go in minus
rather a lot of time so
um
okay let's i don't want to hijack the
whole thing
we can we can use this as a as a basis
right
forward
okay
this is
um
yeah this is perhaps worth talking about
um
we can't get to this today
the others can definitely wait
um
what the heck is this
tangibly used for exceeding recursion
limit
right so see that example
is that what it does now
that what it does in the current 13-1
master builds
it's controlled by a system
which is different from that from what
it did before which is just say dollar
recursion dollar restoration limit and
then return to top level correct
and it returned this
something with uh hold in some random
place
you know that and or crashed
right
well i mean the difference that this is
not returning yeah
right through it's it's throwing an
exception now rather than returning but
yes it's completely aborting the
computation that's going to cause
endless bizarre bugs
uh well it's uncovering endless bizarre
bugs yeah so
the old behavior of um turning into a
hold of
no doubt
yeah i've no doubt it's just that people
have assumed that behavior
right
and so so yes in fact we have well it
hasn't caused as much breakage as we
might have worried but we have uh found
three bugs
where things were secretly recursing
infinitely and then just
but it was hidden behind quiet so
right and so
so two have already been fixed and the
third will presumably be fixed
um but but we need to pick this up more
carefully i mean i understand what i
understand what you're saying
i mean how deadly is the system
exception it's pretty deadly right i
mean it's just everything exits around
it's just an exception well but
right but you can catch it
so but yes so i introduced it for the
case i originally introduced system
exception for the case where we ran out
of memory but we didn't want to call
that colonel noman johnson that said the
kernel is quitting because it didn't
have enough memory
right so in the case where you've run
out of memory it's the choice between
crashing and between completely aborting
the yeah so that that was an easy call
right right
now this i i will 100 concede that this
is a much closer call so let's pick this
up next time it'll at least i mean the
basic issue is
how deadly
in other words
boy
i mean i've got to tell you that i think
i can imagine cases
where i've got a table and some things
work just fine you have 7 18 whatever
and then one of them is some bizarre
iteration limit i don't want to kill the
whole table as a result of that but you
don't you the point is with the system
exceptions you don't have to because you
could put a catch no no but i don't know
that there's not enough catch i don't
know there's supposed to be a catch
well it tells you and then you fix your
program
you you get the message and then nobody
gets the message having not got the list
out you just get an uncaught throw
okay and this i think is the reason why
this this whole discussion should relate
to what uh
christopher connor leonid are doing with
the exception handling
i think we have a meeting yes even later
this week i mean uh leonid has a very
nice prototype of like using failure
object for this
which contain the stack of the
computation that you can see exactly
where it failed what was the last thing
executed
okay
that's gonna be much more helpful uh
figuring out what went wrong all right
sounds good by the way
is this is this is
is this a steven meeting is this meeting
just you and them
no there's been
i mean they've been meeting for one year
i typically join when i have time so
once every month or so but uh
i think it's ece
the name i i'm
the name of the group but that's not
the question that which which it is
asking is is this surfacing into a
meeting with me for final design stuff
or is it still i think his initial
design stuff uh the the look so there's
a meeting being scheduled
uh i see a meeting organized by you
with your name
okay
great i look forward to it
um ethan by the way comments on a live
stream that whatever we do with progress
better work on a terminal but you know
that already it's already working it
already works on the terminal
great
all right i'm sorry i've been a little
rushed here um
okay
good stuff more to discuss next time